i wonder if you can do some kinds of
like um
simulations of like
you know different proteins or
multi-protein systems going to war
against each
other like to try to figure out um you
know
reinforcement learning is used in alpha
zero for example to learn chess and go
and that's using the self-play mechanism
where the thing plays against itself
sure and learns better and better yeah
whether you can i wonder if you can
simulate almost evolution in that way
for us for primitive biological systems
have them in stimulation
fight each other and then see what comes
out like a super dangerous virus comes
out or super like chuck norris type of
thing that defends against the super
dangerous virus and it's all in
simulation so an example would be
we have all these variants of sarsko v2
arising right
which which
looked to be selected by uh immune
responses
but we now we know what amino acids are
changing in the spike
and how they block antibody binding you
could simulate that you could say
what what is the antibody looking at you
these are where antibodies bind on
proteins are called epitopes right you
could map them all and change them in a
simulation one by one and and go back
and forth between the antibody and the
virus so all these
evolution is what we call an arms race
right the virus changes
and then it evades the host and then the
host can change the host takes longer to
change though unfortunately it takes
geological time but it can and then the
virus can change and it can go back and
forth and we can see evidence of this
in genome sequences of both viruses and
their hosts and so
you can take a protein
in a host that is a receptor for
multiple viruses and you can see all the
impacts of virus pressure on it and you
could simulate that for sure and that's
just one thing that you could do you
could simulate
changes in say
an enzyme that makes it resistant to a
drug and predict all the drug resistance
but but the problem is
people like me the experimental
virologist don't know how to do any of
that so we need to collaborate
with people i guess oh with other humans
we do that we do that okay but with
people from a field that we're not used
to like i suppose people who
would it be ai i suppose yeah machine
learning people machine learning people
and you would say look
this is the biological problem is there
a way we can use your tools to attack it
the problem is those people
are
anti-social introverts
that
have a place like this and try to hide
from other people in the world very
difficult to find in the wild
you